on va voir bien étayer un programme où
chaque coup et chaque dépense est
expliqué nous allons équilibrer le
budget en 2019
il nous allons faire tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour créer la croissance dont
les canadiens ont besoin dans les années
à venir
alors voilà c'est ce n'était pas tout à
fait les bons extrême et vous avez vu
les chefs puis c'est pas ils
n'intéressent à alex chantal michel
bonsoir à vous dire que nous traitons la
mouture poser qu'aujourd'hui elle a duré
tard après 78 jours il ya des extraits
comme ça chantal vous pouvez répondre au
téléphone pendant que excusez moi si je
suis partagé non non c'est une réunion à
bon soyons sérieux gouvernement
minoritaire c'était le thème la journée
denis nous allons parler mais hélas bien
sûr monsieur mulcair monsieur truc tout
qui disent oh grand jamais je dis
chapeau sûrement pas ça au grand jamais
nous allons appuyer un gouvernement
minoritaire conservateur donc il aura
forcément une durée de vie très très
court première tour de table là dessus
d'abord sur la notion de gouvernement
minoritaire mais aussi sur cette notion
de minorités à conservateur il ira pas
très loin disent les mêmes depuis le
jour 1 du début de cette campagne là on
savait que si gouvernement était
conservateur minoritaire
sa durée de vie est limitée parce
qu'après neuf ans de gouvernement
conservateur va manquer donc assez
fatigué assez usés et que surtout et
justin trudeau et thomas montrer leurs
partisans au beaucoup vu un gouvernement
assez prévisible on n'allait pas lui
laisser le bénéfice du doute comme ça
avait été le cas en 2006 et 2008
à moins d'être très très près d'une
majorité à quelques sièges l'on pourrait
justifier d'avoir quand même un mandat
ces fadas population un simple
gouvernement minoritaire conservateur
allait avoir de la difficulté est ce que
ça veut dire qu'il va voir une alliance
ponctuelle lors des autres partis un
vrai gouvernement de coalition beaucoup
de scénarios existent mais avoir un
gouvernement conservateur minoritaire
pendant deux ou trois ans
ça veut aussi dire qu'ils sont peut-être
plus confiant je parle de monsieur
trudeau en ses moyens au diable ce matin
d'abord est-ce qu'on peut s'entendre sur
le fait qu'une suite nous et monsieur
wenger ont déclaré cei a déjà trois
semaines quand les conservateurs avaient
beaucoup plus de chances d'être en piste
pour un gouvernement minoritaire ou
majoritaire qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
on est un peu en train d'avoir une
discussion de sciences politiques qui
risquent de passer à l'histoire
parce que la tendance va pas dans le
sens d'un gouvernement minoritaire
conservateur de toute façon mais il ya
des lésions voulu river clou aujourd'hui
en tout cas ils en ont reparlé à ce
qu'on leur reposer la question patrie si
dans les faits ils l'ont dit ses thèmes
et tony ya trois semaines et c'était
sans précédent dans l'histoire du canada
que les deux chefs des principaux partis
d'opposition déclare dans une campagne
électorale
vous pouvez les lire mais j'aurai deux
raisons parce que monsieur trudeau a dit
ce même dans la première entrevue j'ai
fait au début de la campagne éclair dans
tout bon mais la tendance est vert et
gouvernement libéral la question doit se
poser mais n'y arrive c'est est-ce que
le gouvernement va être libéral
majoritaire ou minoritaire
on peut plus axé sur une majorité
libérale bien qu'on écrit encore
actuellement territoire minoritaires il
faudra voir quelle vitesse les choses se
passe d'ici la fin de la semaine
il reste plus beaucoup de temps pour
change énormément de choses mais je
pense que là bas et de parler l ai pas
parlé en bleu n'ont cessé de parler
ayant un sondage vous ne verrez pas et
qu'en mai un nouveau sondage
d'où le nouveau deux nouveaux essais
35,6 parti libéral donc 36 partis
conservateurs 31 npd 20 donc les
libéraux qui confirme sondage après
sondage
leur avance nationale vous monde en eau
thériault et au québec même même sondage
ekos ontario d'abord regardé libéraux
les vraiment ils ont décollé en ontario
43% 31 pour les conservateurs le npd à
10 est bon bon là on prend ça donne
exactement et le québec le québec
là c'est extrêmement étonnant regardez
les libéraux 30,9 31% égalité avec le
npd conservateurs 17 et le bloc à 13 bon
petit d'échantillonnage donc attention
attention tous créateurs et il est
notamment co phone
peste parce que moi je pense que les
libéraux certainement font une plainte
du vote fédéraliste est donc improbable
dans les circonscriptions où ils ont
trop de bottes puis dans québec
francophone ils sont probablement pas en
première place mais on ne sait pas il
est champion et le bloc à 13 me semblent
sous-estimer
mais quand hier on a entendu monsieur
trudeau faire un appel aux conservateurs
aux progressistes-conservateurs du pays
c'est qu'il sent lui aussi qu'à une base
solide bien sûr chez ses électeurs
traditionnels mais la kippa les ratisser
plus large
il le sent un chantal qui a le vent dans
les voiles il ya deux choses d'abord
tout le monde s'entend justin trudeau
de toute façon a gagné sa campagne dans
le sens où il est le seul qui a dépassé
toutes les attentes les libéraux même
plan revenait au pouvoir en 2000 etc
sion c'est la première alors nous avons
pas besoin il n'y a pas de faire coter
d'autre part les chiffres sont
effectivement positif et ce que justin
trudeau veux faire c'est convaincre ceux
qui se demandent encore s'ils devaient
rester avec le npd aller vers lui que le
voilà il est là et qu'en plus il est
acceptable
il est ici lui se dit là si tout va bien
encore quatre cinq jours ça y est ça
fonctionne il se sent comme ça chez les
libéraux il ya encore une marge d'un dc
intéressant aller chercher pour le parti
libéral
c'est le cas pour le npd aussi l'équipe
plutôt stable ou même les gens remonter
dans différentes régions où l'on se bat
pour les indécis mais ces indécis les
deux ne vont pas au parti conservateur
et c'est les variations qu'on voit dans
les sondages leur base est là mais ne
progresse plus bien une bouche publié en
30 31
avant les libéraux le npd se battre pour
les indécis comme les libéraux ont un
avantage un ascendant actuellement dans
les sondages mais ayant grimpé la
majeure partie est destinée aux élèves
c'est là qu'on voit que l'écart entre le
second le je vais loin mais comme ces
raisons il faut que je vous parle parce
que delachaux préparation pour la soirée
électorale
est ce que ça pourrait selon vous allez
même jusqu'à un gouvernement majoritaire
et ben est-ce que ça pousse il peut
aller jusque là ce n'est plus impossible
moi je pense qu'ils ont encore un
territoire minoritaire mais à un moment
donné quand on commence souvenez-vous de
la grâce à un moment donné qu'un ça
prend une certaine ampleur cette
histoire là
ça s'arrête plus est-ce qu'on va se
rendre là gens je suis pas certain si
j'avais de l'argent m là tu aujourd'hui
je le ferais pas mais on peut plus
l'exclure qu'ils soient majoritaires à
la fin de l'opération
ce qui est certain c'est que par exemple
les conservateurs pour se remettre dans
la course pour former un gouvernement
ont besoin gagné un point par jour et
aujourd'hui c'est encore une journée où
ils n'ont pas gagné ça vaut aussi pour
les libéraux qui ont besoin de gagner un
point par jour s'ils veulent se rendre à
une majorité ce qui n'est pas évident
l'eau les profits ce qui est non il n'ya
pas malgré le tassement du vote
conservateur je le disais que
probablement atteint un plancher pas
d'effondrement du vote conservateur on
vient on reviendra pas la droite divisée
qui permettait aux libéraux de rafler
l'ontario lho complet où on va avoir une
base conservatrice encore solide qui
pour ramasser des comptes et donc il est
quand même on se rappellera les libéraux
sont pas de sac à 36 37 sièges à une
solution lâchant il faut qu'un ramasse
plus de cent trente neuf pour être mais
c'est quand même une haute marche à
monter pour le parti libéral la majorité
pas exclu mais la marche quand même car
quand tu as du vote npd qui peut s'en
aller aux libéraux sur le principe soit
d'aller avec le gagnant soit de jouer
stratégique de dire on va être bien
certain de battre stephen harper s'agit
a encore du moule ada qui est possible
on verra si ce meilleur marquer quand on
est rendu à 17 % en ontario là on est
pas mal rangés à sa bande très bien je
le disais c'est la dernière fois quand
je parle avant l'avant la soirée
électorale
je vous demande les hauts-lieux moment
marca déterminant de cette campagne là
selon vous je fais un tour de table avec
probablement le moment où justin trudeau
a promis de faire trois déficits
consécutifs le qui est un peu contre
intuitif pour un chef en campagne
électorale le premier des déficits alors
qu'on est pas vraiment en situation de
récession profonde
c'est pourtant nécessairement la
position qui le prise comme le message
que ça envoyait d'avoir une capable de
prendre des décisions qui sont un peu
difficiles et controversé pour un chef
qu'on ne serait pas prêt pour minutes
c'est déjà quelque chose qui était
différent pourtant ils veulent vendre le
mayweather et porte avions basés mari
boine à l'ess a permis de le
différencier aussi assez clairement du
npd les battait pour les mêmes vote
celui du changement et c'était plus
audacieux que la plateforme du npd
ceci dit quand on lit les deux le npd
est encore parti de gauche là il n'ya
pas devenu sur une mort partie 2 sans
fil
les eaux ne sont pas rien à personne si
la présentation ou aussi envoyer un
message très différent qu'il y en a qui
lui a dit être déterminé
pour moi c'est effectivement un mr
mélange les deux il ya cette position là
mais aussi la décision de monsieur
manqué d'insister pour dire qu'ils
allaient équilibrer le budget tous les
ans d'un exercice néo démocrates alors
c'est le contraste entre les deux et ça
me monsieur marqueurs dans une boîte
dont il n'a pas réussi à sortir je vais
jouer assure les cinq débats quand même
parce que sur cinq des bars à chaque
débat l'appui aux nivéaux progresser
donc sans risque
et ça ça compte ça simple et on le
disait les attentes comme elle était
plus basse ce trudeau les à dépasser
allègrement de 2,2 points tournants
quand monsieur mike 1 dès le début de la
campagne se fait attaquer en disant qu
est un visage à deux faces qui disent
pas la même chose en français et en
anglais
il n'a jamais bien répondu à ça ce qui
fait que c'est devenu quasiment du
folklore populaire ça c'est une grave
erreur en campagne électorale
deuxièmement je dirais le débat manques
il y avait eu un mauvais débat en
français le sucre hulot est un excellent
des baumes puis à partir de ce moment là
tout le monde du vélo
si la patrie bûcher à ce moment-là il
trébuche sera probablement pas et ça lui
a donné une nouvelle stature de campagne
puis il s'est bien monté façon sérieuse
impression qu est-ce que les gens auront
les électeurs auront d'air vous avez eu
les chiffres que j'ai donné tout à
l'heure c'est 80 % d'augmentation de
l'héritière la 3,6 millions sont allés
voter par anticipation c'est énorme 80 %
de plus qu'en 2011 on les rend vraiment
prudente vis-à-vis ça parce qu'il me
semble que d'une élection à l'autre les
gens comprennent qu'ils ont pu besoin
d'avoir une excuse sur la lumière c'est
vrai mais là on verra au 115 toute
participation mais c'est pas la
barbastelle 61% la dernière fois pour
que ça dépasse donc je les électeurs la
question qui vont se poser en mettant la
petite croix le sujet qui va être
déterminant pour eux selon vous je pense
encore que la volonté de changement très
très forte en fait c'est la seule donnée
qui était constante du but
la fin de cette campagne électorale de
60 75 pour cent des canadiens disent
qu'on doit passer à un autre
gouvernement que ce soit l'impudique sur
l'île perrot qui s'échangent la tête npd
était en tête au début maintenant c'est
les libéraux ça ça n'a à peu près pas
bougé donc oui il vote par anticipation
peut être un déplacement du vote totale
parce qu'effectivement les gens peuvent
aller voter mais ça peut aussi des gens
existent bel et on va passer à d'autres
choses qui avons une volonté de
changement un peu plus forte que
d'habitude et qu'on le voit dans le taux
de participation final c'est aussi
possible
on verra mais les gens avant a eu une
très longue campagne et ont pu se faire
une idée ça fait un petit moment ils
étaient prêts à user des prêts à voter
maintenant adulte ablement le changement
les gens nous posent encore la même
question aujourd'hui que la première
journée pensez vous que ce qui venant
après le vote ferment généralement en
quoi ça quand on est compétition l'égard
du patient ce qui va mourir
mais et c'est une partie du problème du
npd qui avaient tous parier sur le fait
qu'ils étaient en tête dans les sondages
et que donc il y allait avoir cet élan
lie à les regarder aller
le jour où ils ont perdu cette trame
narrative et ya risque que ce qu'on voit
dans les sondages c'est à dire qu'ils
seront des plus mais parce que c'est
plus important cette année que d'à peu
près dans n'importe quel autre élection
depuis 15 ans parce que le cycle aussi
qui se termine michel moi je suis
d'accord c'était c'était la question
qu'on pensait qu'ils étaient des
questions disait loi le premier jour
seul est encore une question qui se pose
beaucoup moins par exemple c'est parce
que justin trudeau peut être premier
ministre
elle se posait beaucoup au début de la
campagne s'il a réussi par sa
performance à apaiser apaise ces
craintes leurs hobbies et très bien mais
patrice y était chef du npd je suis pas
sûr qu'il serait à cette place là dans
les comptages ont dit monsieur malgré
une campagne prudente
un programme prudent mais peut-être
trouvé quoi se permettre d'avoir
nécessairement programme aussi audacieux
alors les gens regardent du sein trudeau
et se disent moi mais à la fin c'est
parti libéral s'est passé comme nixon en
chine que les démocrates auraient pas pu
y aller sélection moins louches pour
justin dires du bruno dire on va
dépenser plus en paix des 10 sociétés
amies c'est terminé chacun répond c'est
l'humain moderne
c'est un plaisir mais on va se revoir
bientôt on se revoit la soirée soumettra
voie après l'élection
et c'est pas fini merci nous avons
encore patrice